Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Papumba is an educational games
developer based in Argentina
with a core team of
four people and a vision
to grow a global business.
Check out this video linked
in the description below
to learn how working
with a team of experts
from across the
world and adapting
their games to local markets
helps them find success
globally.
If you love robots like I do,
this newly open source library
is for you.
It's called
Cartographer, and it's
a real time simultaneous
localization
and mapping, or slam library,
in 2D and 3D with [? ROS ?]
support.
For more details and some
videos of it in action,
check out the post.
Google App Engine
offers a variety of user
sign-in options, but what if
you need a full stack solution
for authentication,
including verifying access
tokens on the server?
Take a look at this
article to learn
about Firebase authentication.
A complete sign-in
experience that provides
a drop-in UI, powerful
SCKs, and back-end services
for token verification.
You can now run ASP.NET core
apps on Google App Engine
by packaging them in
a Docker container.
Take a look at the post for
steps on how to get started.
And you can now
download the latest book
in our No Nonsense series
called the No Nonsense
Guide to Native Ads.
It's designed to provide
a comprehensive overview
of native ads and share
practical tips and best
practices for implementing
native ads in your app.
To get your copy,
follow the link below.
You need tools that help you
build mobile first experiences
at scale.
AdWords Editor is here
to help and just in time
for the holidays.
The latest version
includes support
for universal App Campaigns,
g-mail ad templates,
and much more.
Details on the post.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[COMPUTER NOISES]